buenos días ya se han escuchado 41
cañonazos durante 41 minutos en todas
las naciones del reino unido en
gibraltar y en los buques británicos en
altamar para honrar la memoria del duque
de edimburgo para celebrar su vida su
rol en la familia real y también para
homenajear ese papel tan importante que
tuvo dentro de la monarquía de ser el
soporte la roca de la reina isabel aquí
en las afueras del palacio de buckingham
siguen como mencionas acercándose
miembros del público a presentar sus
condolencias a la familia real en
especial a la reina a quienes resaltan
ha perdido a su amado esposo se respira
un ambiente de mucho respeto siguen
acercándose cada vez más integrantes del
público la familia real les ha pedido
que no lo hagan que no vengan a este
lugar ni tampoco dejen flores a las
afueras del castillo de windsor donde
murió ayer el duque de edimburgo por las
actuales restricciones del confinamiento
pido que hagan donaciones de flores de
recursos a algunas de las 800
organizaciones de caridad de las que el
duque de edimburgo fue su patrón ese es
el ambiente que se respira a esta hora
aquí en las afueras del palacio como
ustedes pueden ver a mi espalda cada vez
siguen y siguen llegando más miembros
del público luisa le pregunto ahora
cuáles son los detalles que se conocen
el funeral del príncipe
no se han ultimado esta es una decisión
de la reina isabel que será comunicada
se espera en las próximas horas lo que
se sabe es que el duque de edimburgo
quería un funeral sencillo más de
carácter militar recordemos que él tuvo
un papel muy importante una carrera muy
exitosa en los años 50 como piloto y
también durante la segunda guerra
mundial así que su corazón está mucho
más cerca de las fuerzas militares
quiere un funeral o quería un funeral en
el que las fuerzas militares fueran
protagonistas así que se sabe que será
además privado e incluso se habla que
por las estrictas normas del
confinamiento que vive en inglaterra en
el que a partir de este lunes no más de
30 personas pueden reunirse para un
funeral ni siquiera la familia real
completa podría reunirse para dar el
último adiós al duque de edimburgo así
que esa es la situación se espera que
los próximos horas en los próximos
minutos la familia real la propia reina
isabel esté anunciando a través de un
comunicado cuáles serán esos detalles se
cree que el funeral
será en ocho días lo hizo también le
quiero preguntar por último cómo estará
seguridad en la zona y también si se
sabe algo de los príncipes del príncipe
harry contará también esta polémica de
su esposa megan marcos y también del
príncipe william
claro la seguridad por supuesto está
ahora en las afueras del buckingham
palace es enorme hay gran presencia
policial incluso afuera de las rejas del
palacio de buckingham no sé si ustedes
alcanzan a observarlo hay seguridad
privada y también hay una especie de
fila para que las personas puedan entrar
organizadamente a dejar las flores se
dice que el príncipe harry quien está en
medio de la polémica por esta entrevista
que dio con su esposa megan markel en la
que denunció que ella no se le
atendieron requerimientos de problemas
de salud mental y también de anuncios de
racismo podría venir aquí al reino
unido- usando su pasaporte diplomático
para poder estar con su abuelo se dice
que el príncipe harry era el nieto
favorito del duque